ok ça c'est la base maintenant essayez
de varier
1 2 3 4 1 2 3 4 1 2 3 4 5 et 6 1 2 3 4 5
et 6 et 1 2 1 2 le flou en éléments
importants dans le rap le rythme la
façon dont tu on prononce les mots dans
une chanson la rappeuse précis de Saane
mais cet atelier rap pour les enfants
dans le cadre du festival Les Escales
urbaine à plaisir ce que je vais faire
c'est d'essayer d'activer le vocabulaire
passive déjà on a tous eu plein de mots
dans nos têtes qui sont gardés au fond
et qu'on utilise pas quotidien donc là
le bus ça va être d'aller chercher ce
vocabulaire pour pouvoir le mettre après
dans les textes pour pouvoir faire des
punchline des jeux de mots et après je
vais faire un travail sur la musicalité
sur la musicalité sur le compte
apprendre à bien quand est la musique
pour cela la rappeuse propose des petits
exercices pour apprendre à créer des
variations et des interprétation
différente par exemple ce jeu de rimes
les enfants doit se faire des passes
passe de mots qui riment le but
réfléchir vite pour pouvoir improviser
on va dire des rimes et c'est lui qui
est si on arrive pas en 10 secondes une
éliminé ça me plaît mais quelquefois
c'est dur de nous en prendre un petit
café de la musique et nous fait des
travaux sur les rimes exetera tous à la
façon de s'exprimer écrire des petits
textes et apprendre à poser sa voix le
rap et donc accessible pour les enfants
objectif transmettre des idées à travers
les textes